[Music]
Scream 6 is currently running in
theaters and was the most successful
release ever for Wes Craven's famous
horror franchise the movie grossed an
impressive 44 million US Dollars on its
opening weekend after the success of
Scream 5 in 2022 led to a prop sequel
history is now repeating itself as the
website screen geek revealed Scream 7 is
already being worked on at full speed
many were amazed when the new Scream
movie starring Wednesday star Jenna
Ortega hit theaters just one year after
part 5 but horror flicks are known for
being profitable even with moderate box
office takings since they can be
produced comparatively fast and at low
cost screen 6 is no exception the budget
of 35 million dollars has already been
recouped after the opening weekend
shooting for Scream 7 is therefore
scheduled to begin as early as 2023 so
we expect the theatrical release next
year should the success continue we
might actually be able to look forward
to a new screen film every year in the
future have you watched Scream 6 in
theaters yet and what do you think about
the fast output of new Ghostface movies
feel free to share your thoughts in the
comments
[Music]
thank you foreign